Are you a sociopath?
Have you been caught with your pants
down figuratively or literally in some
cases?
Do you want to rejoin your moral
community and wind back the respect of
your peers,
but don't want to admit that you're
wrong.
Well,
you've come to the right place today.
We're going to learn about the art of
the non-apology.
We're going to take you from this.
I did not have sexual relations with
that woman to this from this.
Hey everybody.
It's me,
Kathy Griffin.
I'm just now seeing the reaction of
these images.
I made a mistake and I was wrong to this
year.
This month.
That picture was released by the way you
take the apology back
if you're lucky from this
and when you were starting to let you do
it.
I can do anything
to this.
What a great honor to be able to
introduce for the first time ever
anywhere.
The 45th president of the United States
of America,
Donald J dot trump.
Grandmother.
Alright,
let's do this number one.
Don't apologize.
Let's start with the bread and butter.
Have you tried not apologizing?
This is called the John Wayne Approach.
Oh No,
so just out by the waterfall,
but I'm sorry.
It's never apologize,
Mr.
to sign of weakness.
This is often perceived by your
supporters as being strong and powerful.
You don't have to apologize.
No matter what you do.
This technique is endorsed by Donald
Trump.
We are not going to apologize for
America no more apologies,
and before you say there goes crazy,
trump changing American politics to be
insensitive.
Just remember,
this has been an American stands for
pretty much forever.
I'll never apologize for the United
States of America ever.
I don't care what the facts are,
no matter what the facts are.
This is America number two account.
Don't apologize.
Okay,
so if not,
apologizing isn't an option.
You've really stepped in the Doodoo.
Try Accounting.
This is when you don't apologize.
You explained the context of when you
messed up and that supposedly justifies
the action.
If they hadn't bought the liquor,
you wouldn't have been drinking,
and if you hadn't been drinking,
you wouldn't have sent those
embarrassing photos of yourself.
Roseanne put on a clinic of accounting a
few weeks ago when she said,
oh no,
I didn't mean to tweet something.
People interpreted as racist.
I was on Ambien,
which made me sleep.
Tweet.
Rosanne has her CPA in accounting.
Great stuff.
Roseanne sets the bar.
Number three,
apologize but don't change.
Now,
this next one is a long con.
You're going to say that you're sorry,
but then commit a string of activities
that show that you really haven't
changed.
This next example is a little long.
I of course am talking of Anthony's
wieners apology.
This is him in 2011.
When the scandal first breaks last
Friday night,
I tweeted a photograph of myself that I
intended to send us a direct message as
part of a joke to a woman in Seattle.
So today I'm announcing my resignation
from Congress and two years later he
tries to repair his image.
Look,
I made some big mistakes and I know I
let a lot of people down,
but I've also learned some tough lessons
breaking news.
I'm responsible for this behavior that
led us to be in this place.
I want you again say sorry to anyone who
has received receiving end of these
messages.
This is a pretty risky maneuver.
A can backfire pretty hard,
so please be careful with this one.
Number four clarified.
Don't apologize.
Another tactic is to say that your
accuser misunderstood or misinterpreted
you.
You really meant something else.
For this example,
take a look at Megan Kelly,
confronting Donald trump about his own
record.
History of misogyny.
I don't want to sound too much like a
chauvinist,
but you wouldn't have your job if you
weren't beautiful.
It's very sad.
I'd look at right in that fat,
ugly face.
She's gotten a little bit larger.
Person who's flat chested is very hard
to be a 10.
She ate like a pig,
but what does he do?
Does he sit there and take it?
Does he apologize?
No,
he clarifies it.
He says,
I wasn't talking about women.
I was talking about Rosie O'donnell.
You've called women.
You don't like fat pigs,
dogs,
slobs,
and disgusting animals.
Your twitter account,
only rosie o'donnell.
This can be extremely effective.
Onto the next example.
Number five,
issue a statement but never actually
say,
sorry.
So let's say you're Hillary Clinton,
someone running under the banner of
women's rights and you find yourself in
trouble for not firing in 2008 campaign
advisor who is accused of sexual
harassment.
Well,
what is she going to do?
Watch this play by play.
She issues a series of tweets where she
explains herself,
but notice she never uses apologize or
sorry,
anywhere in here.
Now you amateurs out there pay special
attention to this next part.
See we call this.
The Washington doubled down.
She gets caught out for that and then
she goes on to explain herself further
in a really long facebook apologies,
but still doesn't use words like
apologizer.
Sorry.
So it looks like she's apologizing,
but she really isn't.
Now before we move onto our last type of
non-apology in this video,
let's take a second to analyze why
someone might use not apologies.
Non-Apology is used for two reasons.
First,
apologizing is all about not making
excuses,
taking blame and putting yourself in the
hands of the offended.
This is difficult if you're in a
position of power,
it can make you feel weak.
It can cause legal issues because
apologizing means you're admitting guilt
and some people simply don't like
admitting when they're wrong.
The second reason is maybe in your.
You haven't committed a large enough
offense to warrant an apology.
For this reason,
you might issue a halfhearted.
Sorry.
Different people have different
thresholds for what deserves an apology.
Either way,
it's worth knowing that if you do decide
to go the route of the non-apology,
they often come off as unsatisfying at
best and unfeeling.
At worst.
As you may have noticed in this video,
humans have a natural instinct for
sensing if an apology is sincere and if
the apologizers just trying to weasel
their way out of the offense.
If you doubt this,
think of how unsatisfying these phrases
are.
I'm sorry you got offended,
or if I hurt anybody,
then I apologize.
Still not.
Apologies do have their place.
Sometimes they have social utility and
sometimes they're all you can do as
Edwin [inaudible] Astella points out in
his book.
Sorry about that.
The language of public apology.
To illustrate this,
he brings up a historical example.
When in 1968 during the Vietnam war,
North Korean forces captured the USS
Pueblo,
a ship gathering Intel on the North
Koreans,
North Korea claimed the Pueblo had
crossed the territory lines,
making them fair game for capture while
the US insisted it hadn't.
The crew was tortured and forced to sign
confessions,
and North Korea threatened that if the
US didn't give a written apology for
straying into their territory that
killed the crew.
After being stalled and diplomacy for
almost a year,
Gilbert Woodward,
the Army Major General at the time,
signed an agreement that the US was at
fault.
While simultaneously releasing this
remark,
my signature will not and cannot alter
the facts.
I will sign the document to free the
crew and only to free the crew.
This non apology that was signed by
Woodward is a perfect example of how
insincere apology is can sometimes be
the only answer.
The next day the Pueblos crew was
released safely,
but now that we've talked about why
someone might use a non-apology,
how they come off as insincere and the
rare cases where they're needed.
Let's move onto our final example.
Number six.
I'm sorry,
but apologies.
Let's say you're Caitlyn Jenner.
You just ran a 69 year old from behind
with your car,
so you're being held accountable for
murder.
How do you get out of it?
This one we're going to play along at
home a say you're sorry.
Be Blaming on the Paparazzi.
See settled the lawsuit with your
enormous wealth and don't face jail time
or d,
all of the above.
Yes,
that's right.
To all of you who gets d,
You are correct.
You do it all when you can't totally
dodged the apology.
You can say you're sorry,
but that it wasn't all your fault.
This is what Caitlyn does.
She says she's sorry,
but the Paparazzi were the ones
distracting her and they should also be
held responsible.
She has it all figured out and for the
record she never face jail time.
Totally got away with manslaughter.
He just said manslaughter.
No,
a lot
of my recent remarks you've got up here
before you to say to.
I'm deeply
Lisa,
I think fortunate video.
First of all,
music Mecca,
83.
You've seen them on here before.
Incredible guy.
Go check him out.
We've got a new artist named Ebraheem.
I think that's how you pronounce it.
Anyway,
incredible producer.
If you like his sounds,
go check them out.
All the links to the music art down
below discussion.
Go to the reddit will have a thread.
I also want to discuss with you guys
Patrion I've realized after doing this
channel for a little while,
that that's gonna have to be the main
income source for this channel.
Um,
I just don't release videos fast enough.
I prefer quality.
I prefer spending my time on videos,
so that's going to be,
have to be the direction of the channel.
So you will see more pitches for that.
I apologize if you're annoyed by that,
but the patrons had that have been
supporting me.
Those guys are the kind of the lifeblood
of this channel.
So I'm pushing more towards that.
Along those lines.
I want to change up kind of what we do
with that.
So as you know,
we have two tiers.
Some of you know we have the proletariat
and the bourgeoisie.
Proletarian is $1 a month,
virtually cs $5 a month.
In the past.
I haven't done anything with it.
I want to change that.
I'm not exactly sure how I'm going to,
but for now I want to try this.
If you are currently supporting me or
you are considering supporting me,
go to Patrion.
I'm going to create a thread and I'm
asking for input on what you'd like to
see.
Would you like to see perks?
Would you like to see more recognition?
Would you like to see nothing at all?
I need your feedback to know kind of the
direction I want to go with this.
What makes you want to support your
input?
Really means the world to me,
so please go and put in your two cents a
one last little announcement and then
we're done.
I'm about to leave for my honeymoon so I
will be gone for about little over a
week and then I will be back.
I think I'm going to do a look back at
one of my first viral videos for the
next one.
Maybe something people got mad at me
for,
so look forward to that.
Thank you for watching.